[Applause]
i want to talk about these uh
spotify joe rogan rumors
this is adorable yeah so there's so
apparently
there's a news story out there that is
um there's employees at spotify that are
threatening to strike
if spotify doesn't have editorial
control
over joe rogan's content okay
now as far as i'm concerned i can't find
any proof that this is actually
happening
oh interesting yeah so
i don't know if this is even real what i
assume this is
is a journalist of some sort a blogger
if you will
probably had a friend that works at
spotify
and the friend says yo i heard some
people are not happy about
you know rogan's episodes they might
strike or something
um hearsay nonsense it's it's no
different than me and you going
yo you know what we gotta do some shows
in iceland man that'd be dope to do some
shows in iceland
and then all of a sudden people vlogging
there's a new comedy tour flagrant twos
going to iceland okay
right no official report of any have you
read any official reporters no but i've
read it in enough
publications that i assume there's
something to it but that could be my own
just buying in because i saw it on a few
different sites i think that's what it
is i think what happens is when you have
a name
that's as popular and polarizing as
rogan people are going to talk about it
obviously it's clicks right
right this is going to be a clip yep
what we're doing right now obviously
right
totally so so it's like because you
are news you beget news so
people start hearing this information
and then barstool's tweeting it out but
they haven't verified it they haven't
spoken to anybody and then all these
other places are tweeting it out
they haven't verified they haven't
really spoken anybody so
i think it's actually [ __ ] i don't
think there's any strike
because what grounds do they have to
strike have they listened to the music
on their platform
think about it nothing said in any rogan
episode
could possibly be more offensive than
and i know everybody's assuming i'm
going to go gangster rap death metal
country music dixie chicks are always
killing those guys get to the floor
let the bodies hit the floor like
there's all these different things
that's not about a fire drill
so there's all these type of different
types of music where they're killing
people murdering people they're doing
all these kind of crazy things within
the music far more offensive
than like an intellectual discussion
about
15 year old trans kids being able to
mutilate their body
right right so
[Music]
i don't know for me i think you're we're
about to see a very interesting thing
start to happen especially with
a spotify yeah is
these platforms as they start to get
exclusive rights for content have to
decide
if they're a content curator or if
they're a content
aggregator right youtube is no longer
curating content
right they're just like yo put whatever
you want up we're just a platform
you know i mean like we're gonna have
some rules but they're very limited
rules
you know what we will do is we won't put
ad dollars on your crazy video of you
slaughtering a goat
but you can put your video of you
slaughtering a goat up on youtube and
that's fine right
right once you pay for exclusivity on
something
people are going to hold you responsible
for the content that you're putting out
right yeah so now that content is not
beholden to the listeners of the content
it's beholden to all the listeners or
the users of the platform
right and some of those users on that
platform might be like oh my god these
views are so offensive to me take it
down or i'm going to stop using your
platform
cool and they're allowed to say that and
then it's up for the platform to decide
is this person or creator the content
creator
worth potentially losing some people
because they'll bring so many more
yeah which is great for a guy like rogan
because he's the biggest whale there is
he's gonna bring everyone but what if
you're a fledgling podcast
this just gets signed to spotify and
there's pushback
among spotify listeners then you're out
then you're [ __ ] out unless you
change your content this is
it's very simple to me uh
i actually wonder if there's validity to
it because i also and you can correct me
if i'm wrong
aren't there certain episodes that
aren't coming from
youtube onto spotify i don't know the
exact
validity of that maybe there's certain
ones that weren't added
yeah i had heard that i hadn't checked
for myself but i think that's the
that was the rumor that like the alex
jones one important and that's kind of
where i think if they're fake rumors
that's where they snowballed from
if they're real rumors this is what i
would say to any spotify employee
thinking about going on strike we always
tell people know your worth
and normally that's a positive thing hey
ask for more money know your worth
if you're a spotify employee know your
[ __ ] worth it is
six figures so probably low six figures
that's your worth joe rogan's worth nine
figures
yeah who the [ __ ] do you think is more
easily replaceable ah know
your worth you will be jobless and
that's great
because i know plenty of people would
love to work at spotify and wouldn't
give a [ __ ] about a podcast with
intellectual discussions
that's a good point now you got
something i just looked at alex jones
episodes and they're not up
so alex jones episodes are not up there
now to be
uh fair to uh rogan i think he
said he's gonna keep his hundred
favorite episodes on youtube
so the alex jones episode and a bunch of
these other episodes are still available
on youtube so it's not like
he sells the rights to the catalog and
then all those shows just disappear out
of nowhere
that being said they probably did filter
some of the episodes they want which is
fine
and i imagine you if rogan's like all
right if more people are going to watch
it on my platform then that's fine
too yeah but it is interesting and we
are going to see
if enough pressure can be placed and
again i'm not worried about rogan
because rogan can do whatever he wants
i'm concerned with the content creator
that's much smaller than rogan
i think those guys are going to if you
want to go with spotify
rogan got so big you take me as i am and
if not i will walk i have nine and a
half million youtube subscribers anyway
yeah
probably making six figures a month at
least just off youtube that's it
yeah [ __ ] the millions of listeners and
the ad reads j
like i'm good a fledgling podcast this
is
the cost of doing business with bob do
you think that you're not hypocritical
about it like
for me i just don't understand like
there's so much content out there like
there's so many podcasts that um
uh on on spotify that are like focused
on like murder and like rape and like
serial killers and all this other stuff
so it's not like the content
exists in a way that's like pg-only yep
right so
clearly you're diving into this stuff
that's rated r
yep right so what you're dealing that
with now is the policing
of specific ideas it's the idea that
promotes the phobia whereas you could
say hey
this podcast talks about a serial killer
it doesn't cosign
the killing good point now now that
we're talking about promoting the phobia
or promoting
uh negative behavior if you will there's
a lot of music on the platform that you
could
argue promotes negative behavior now if
you're saying hey that's just music it
doesn't make people go out and do stuff
right well yeah maybe these are just
podcasts they don't make people go out
and do stuff why is one more influential
than the other
i mean the reality of the matter is as
influential as joe rogan is
i'm sure there's a lot more people that
want to look like kanye
yeah you know what i also thought just
crossed my mind as you were going
through this
you know whose album i just listened to
on spotify was it
tory lanez so that so that brings us
into the tory discussion
now we can i if i brought that up too
early we can keep talking rogan but the
point is
yeah to your point about like we're
talking about toxic people or whatever
yeah rogan is a guy that has everybody
from every platform on his podcast right
right not everybody does that you can't
promote this guy
right and not promote rogan and leave
certain episodes off my general feeling
is i don't
find businesses i don't have a problem
with their hypocrisy as much because i
know all they care about is money
to me you can be transparently phony in
a sense as a business because that's
like i want
you to just be like yeah all we care
about is money at least you're being
honest right
if spotify is like nah we can't lose
rogan we can lose these 100 employees
you're very easily replaceable there's
it's a [ __ ] pandemic
right recession plenty of people looking
for jobs more plays you and then
small podcasts you're not worth these
listeners you're out
i don't mind that i know they're about
profit so to me
be hypocritical be phony whatever like
you're about money it's not hypocritical
at the end of the day if your only goal
is money
right right right i just had a quick
theory um
i think we might be hearing these things
about the employees over at spotify
maybe because they are unhappy
to hear rogan has some huge deal and
maybe they
were asking for a raise and spotify was
like oh we don't have the money like
i've heard that before and like wait a
minute they turn around and this guy
just got
nine figures
that's interesting now it shows how
stupid they are because bringing
somebody like that over to their
platform
is going to put them in position to get
that raise
right nobody subscribes to spotify
because you work in marketing
you know what i mean like nobody's like
samantha and marketing is there i gotta
sign up for spotify now
ideally if she's doing her job that's
why everybody subscribes yeah but
i'm playing that's because a worse
department to criticize i was hoping you
wouldn't poke a whole lot sanitation
maybe
okay
accounting sure exactly yeah yeah no 100
it's just it for what i really think
this is
i think this is um
political division like i think this is
like
politics or donors or influencers
trying to find a way to silence rogan
and i think they're trying to build
support like i think they're even
stoking a fire that isn't there
i think they're like yeah the employees
are pissed off and then they're hoping
that the employees there go
yeah we are pissed off yeah they're
trying to start the fire that the
employees end up continuing to grow and
then maybe find a way to silence this
guy that they're terrified of
because look what what i always see is
the second rogan talks about
anything right political anything it
doesn't matter if he says i like bible
says i like trump it doesn't matter
the next day immediately he's
discredited yeah right how could you
listen to this guy he's transphobic he's
almost called him
exactly same thing right yeah so i
wonder if this is the powers that be
going hey we got to get this rogan guy
out here and now
we might have the ability to do it
because we could put pressure on the
mother company
right and i think all that would do is
that would just make rogan go
you got to pay me no matter what and i'm
gonna keep putting my [ __ ] out on my
platform yeah
you cannot touch the guy yeah it seems
weird it seems
i think i agree with you it seems like a
fluff piece kind of thing because the
only site like the site that is
reporting all of them like barstool like
mma whatever
is from like digital music news doesn't
seem like that reputable and on top of
that i don't see why the story is only
coming out now when the deal was
announced in like what march april or
something
like why is it like the employees knew
who rogan was when they signed the deal
we knew what the amount allegedly was
when the deal came out why is it only
now
they want to silence him as we come up
to the election when he's saying oh i'll
moderate
the debate i'll moderate a debate i'll
do something political all of a sudden
all these like fluff pieces come out
trying to slander
i think i really think that's it right i
think they're trying to remove him from
political influence
what can we do to remove him from
political can we scare him
can we scare him enough that he won't
bring up these things on his podcast
out of fear that the deal will go away
let's put out enough news stories where
he feels like
he can't say what he wants he can't
share his opinion because he's too
costly and
he doesn't even do it just get in his
head and he'll he'll tiptoe if he's like
oh should i say it or should i not he'll
pull back
that's that's that's what i think yep i
agree i think that's what it might be
i'm skeptical if there's any spotify
fans that are really like we gonna we're
gonna protest
i don't even know if it's happening on
the inside at all of course not i really
don't think it is and there's no ground
suit because of some of the music that
we've all listened to is
way more foul way more foul no
justification
you could argue that some of the
podcasts that he has on that they might
you know uh
take offense to right you could argue
that they're not
meant to offend the intention is not
meant to offend the attention is some
sort of discourse right it's an
intellectual debate about a
controversial topic that's it
intellectual debate about controversial
topic
saying i'm gonna let the bodies hit the
floor
right saying i'm going to kill this guy
who cheated on me on some dixie chick
[ __ ] i'm going to poison the [ __ ] man
like saying i'm going to sell drugs and
[ __ ] these [ __ ] and i'm going to kill
[ __ ] that are rival gangs
saying all that [ __ ] there's no
intellectual discourse right there no
this is i'm the most badass [ __ ]
yeah and then on top of that if you're
going after the character of the people
themselves
there's artists on there that have way
worse character than right that's true
felonies yeah it's all cautious point
whatever yeah and then then to the tory
lanes point which is interesting you saw
it with six nine where they blacklisted
them and then uh tori put out the album
this uh weekend i guess he put out this
weekend saturday i think yeah
right so he puts out the album and i
think he ends up selling 50 000 copies
or something like that i don't know
that's what academics posted that's
where i get my news shows at
and i went and uh and he wasn't getting
any playlisting and he was com
i think someone was complaining about
that or maybe ack was like saying he
wasn't getting a playlist meaning
he wasn't showing up on these playlists
that spotify has right
and it's really interesting to me
because this is a streaming service
using their influence to suppress an
artist right we saw it also with
uh takashi right
all i thought after that was wait if
they could suppress artists
without admitting they're doing it but
just suppress an artist
can they blow up an artist and if an
artist was signed to a label that was
say a percentage owner
of the streaming platform big equity
owner maybe just big investor
do you think they could blow up that
artist now i'm not saying that this is
the case
yeah absolutely but for some reason
spotify whenever i'm listening to
anything will not stop
recommending machine gun kelly logic and
joyner lucas
i've never listened to any of their
music i'm sure they're nice guys
i've never once said i want to listen to
a machine gun kelly's song except the m
m disc which
i thought was really good outside of
that i've never once i press skip
every single time machine gun kelly
joiner lucas or logic come on i press
skip
i am telling the algorithm do not give
me this music there was a white wrapper
on pandora they kept trying to
send me and i kept thumbs downing
everything and they keep pumping and
they keep pushing that [ __ ]
so that's a very valid point i'm curious
yeah
if you could suppress an artist
can you promote one it could be as
simple as mark pointed out one time the
rap caviar playlist on spotify
is massive just throw this that's a
private playlist though
private playlist but you could replicate
it that might be spotify that is spotify
it might be okay because they have like
your daily drive or something like that
which is an algorithmed
playlist i think the labels cut deals
with the players now we're talking
okay this is where [ __ ] gets interesting
labels
i'm assuming are cutting deals or if you
want to get even more nefarious
stock owners hey we want to own
two million dollars worth of spotify
soccer 20 million dollars worth 100
million
whatever it is we're an early investor
in spotify okay
i'm an early investor in spotify i got
artists
under my label i would like you
to give them a leg up against the
competition
you don't have to make people like the
song but you can keep on putting in
front of them
and that's literally what the algorithm
does how is that any different
than the radio industry yeah
yeah right payola record labels
also like a digital version of payoff
this is digital payola
wait and this is where it gets
interesting record labels back in the
day
they would pay the dj's and i think the
stations in general then it became
illegal
but to play their records right so
realistically the
only way that an artist could get radio
play
is if they had a label right and the
only way that they could get into a
record store at tower records
is if they had a label because the label
had the connections to tower records and
what is it vhm or whatever these these
places were right
internet music comes out fair game for
everybody again
right streaming platforms pop up
now all of a sudden at first it was fair
game for everyone
but now it looks like they're bumping
certain musicians
and giving them a little bit i don't
know uh
more popularity visibility
etc right now we're right back into the
record label model
that we thought we just broke yeah
the new the new empires i think are
going to look a lot like the old ones
the exact same one yeah it's only it's
only transitioned to
the the the streaming platform netflix
looks a lot like tv
you know what i mean like in the sense
of pushing i get so many netflix
originals pushed to me
it's insane yeah everything recommended
for you as a netflix original somehow no
like random shows that they bought from
somebody else they think i would like
it's
always netflix original right the same
it seemed to say and why would you not
yeah if you go invest in the content
you're gonna want people to see it true
and if you're spotify and you're somehow
invested in these artists or vice versa
if you're one of these like uh
i guess labels or i don't even know
managers or something who's
invested in spotify or invested in apple
in one of these streaming
platforms you're going to want to make
sure that your artist is getting all the
juice
all i'm saying is are we about to be put
into a position where
the only way that you can succeed as an
artist is if you are assigned to one of
these
that's the only way you can get the play
because right now youtube is the only
platform
where just a random artist could blow up
because youtube is like we're not going
to be
purchasing anything anymore and they
really just do that because they don't
want to be responsible for the content
that's up there 100
but that might end up being the most
fair playing ground there is mm-hmm yeah
because
spotify is like we don't give a [ __ ] we
we buy who we like we promote their [ __ ]
that's what it is youtube is so scared
of the controversy it just kind of works
out that it's more democratic
you